عقد مجلس الامن الدولي الليله جلسه مناقشه
مفتوحه على المستوى الوزاري حول الاوضاع
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وفي كلمه القاها
خلال الجلسه قال الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو جوتيريش قال ان جميع سكان
قطع غزه يواجهون دمارا على نطاق وسرعه لم
يسبق لهما مثيل في التاريخ الحديث واضاف
جوتيريش انه ما من شيء يمكن ان يبرر
العقاب الجماعي للشعب الفلسطيني كما نبه
الى الحاجه الى المزيد من نقاط العبور الى
غزه من اجل تدفق المساعدات
بسرعه يعاني جميع سكان غزه من الدمار على
نطاق وسرعه لم يسبق لهما مثيل في التاريخ
الحديث ولا شيء يمكن ان يبرر العقاب
الجماعي للشعب الفلسطيني ما زلنا نواجه
عمليات تفتيش صعبه ورفضا غير مبرر للمواد
التي تشتد الحاجه اليها اننا بحاجه الى
المزيد من نقاط العبور الى غزه للحد من
الازدحام وتجنب نقاط الاختناق وينبغي ايضا
استئناف تقديم المساعدات الى غزه عبر
ميناء اشدو في اسرائيل والذي وصلت منه اول
شحنه من الطحين الى القطاع لكن هناك حاجه
الى المزيد كما اننا بحاجه الى الوصول الى
الشمال فمن اصل 29 مهمه انسانيه مخطط لها
لتوصيل الامدادات المنقذه للحياه شمال
وادي غزه تمكنا خلال الاسبوعين الاولين من
الشهر الحالي من انجاز سبع فقط كليا او
جزئيا فقد منعت اسرائيل غالبيه البعثات من
الوصول